donc je lui dis auquel je serai avec toi
me dire il faut pas que ça te fasses de
problèmes certaine je fais mais non mais
je suis pas marié avec airtel je vais
venir avec toi commentaires ce rire et
chansons et gérait le soir chez rtl et
ensuite certes elle est un cri un
quiproquo on s'engueulait un peu avec
christian ollivier il m'a dit bah si
c'est comme ça va ré achat son île on
arrête et du coup j'ai du mal géré ses
rires et chansons même beaucoup moins
vite en annonçant pis pour l'argent
s'arrêter comme ça ça a été j'ai été
chez rire et chansons faire l'émission
de foot avec laurent thibeault que
j'adore et que j'aime et que je
laisserai jamais rien à voir avec moi
bah non en temps je crois
qu'il ya même des gens qu'on dit chers
tels toute façon on sait que tu en as
marre tu fais exprès pour partir parce
que cyril hanouna va faire des émissions
de foot sur europe 1 donc tu vas partir
sur europe 1 j'attends toujours qu'on va
pas en appel il ya rien alors
je sais pas
c'est ça agile vous êtes le chroniqueur
de tout le monde aime détester est-ce
que c'est difficile à vivre au quotidien
juge pas du tout c'est vrai en fait je
sais pas si c'est une force ou une
faiblesse mais je ne tient absolument
pas compte de l'opinion des autres sinon
on n'en sort pas sinon c'est trop dur
joue sajou gillet bien que pour il sait
c'est un des mecs il le sait un des mecs
que je préfère antenne c'est un amour de
mec il sait que je peux compter sur lui
à tout moment bon on est tous d'accord
ici que gilles hamel à l'opposé de ses
tailleurs plateau est écrit et c'est un
mec vraiment sur qui on peut compter
c'est un mec d'une gentillesse extrême
et c'est un voilà c'est quelqu'un que
j'aime et que je vais vraiment il le
sejil et pourra toujours compter sur moi
je n'ai jamais laissé tomber d1 vous
allez me mouvoir non mais vraiment et
gilles et je le dis à chaque fois tout
le monde jeudi gilles c'est quelqu'un
que j'aime profondément qui m'a jamais
lâché qui comprend quand il doit faire
moins d'émissions qui n'aura jamais
martiale mais alain jammes pour se
plaindre je vous jure je n'ai jamais eu
un sms de gilles ou un appel de gilles
me disant oui pourquoi je suis pas là
pourquoi je suis là c'est avant la
saisine rolls lit et quand il est dans
l'émission il travaille à fond et je
dire gilles c'est une rolls des
chroniqueurs quand on prépare l'émission
le matin on dit à chaque fois tu as
songe il aura des infos gilles va et
c'est vrai que gilles vraiment bravo
[Applaudissements]